quand tu bois une guerre il ya celui qui
parle est celui qui écoute ça c'est les
options de ta quand tu viens de te faire
larguer voici l'autocollant qu'on
devrait mettre à la place du ha et ça
c'est le vrai milieu d'un lit double
voilà ce qui se passe dans son estomac
quand tu es invité chez des gens et ça
si le trajet que ton über fait quand tu
l'attends ses dessins c'est moi qui les
ai fait avec ma tête et mon ipad j'en ai
fait des centaines que j'ai regroupé
dans un livre qui s'appelle mes dessins
et qui est déjà dispo franchement c'est
une excellente idée de cadeau de noël
surtout quand tu sais pas quoi offrir
alors achetez le et mettez le en bas de
votre sapin vos proches ne seront pas
déçus